all right Steven this will be our final
worth in Episode four 2019 today I'm
worth it we're going to be trying three
fried chicken sandwiches at three
drastically different price points to
find out which one is the most worth it
and its price
I think we're experiencing at the moment
a little bit of a fried chicken sandwich
craze
we thought we'd investigate the issue
and do fried chicken sandwiches
ourselves I like what you said
investigate oh look at that fresh
asphalt the way you say words it looks
golden and delicious the way fresh fried
chicken does doesn't that look delicious
tasty what so the first place we're
heading to is the window at American
Beauty chef Alicia is going to be
showing us their fried chicken sandwich
American beauty is a steakhouse and
during the day they have a to-go window
that does things like burgers fries
fried chicken sandwiches obviously I
like that a lot it feels very New York I
don't know I'm going that I just like it
I just like New York
what is the window so the window is our
daytime operation where we serve
delicious food at a very affordable
price I understand the chicken sandwich
is under six bucks it has five dollars
and fifty cents
Wow that is crazy I don't know if I'd
say we're competition with fast food but
we're trying to hit around the price
point of the regular fast food chains
we're making everything in-house an idea
is to deliver hospitality to our guests
whether they order a fried chicken
sandwich at the window or they're
ordering our steaks at night so we
butterfly the chicken so it spreads out
you pound it so it's the same thickness
around I saw that you are also scoring
the meat before you were pounding it by
scoring it we're both helping buttermilk
and the seasoning penetrate well so
we're giving a little bit more surface
space so there's a little bit more
crunchy parts then we just fry it we
have the awesome Martin's potato rolls
the jalapeno aioli which gives a little
bit more fat and some heat and then we
have this very simple slaw that gives a
little freshness just cabbage some
carrots red onion and a very simple red
wine vinaigrette is that what you would
say
makes a perfect fried chicken sandwich
is it the balance of all of those things
together for me I think it's really a
combination of it all it's an evolution
while you're eating it and as it goes it
kind of all compliments itself I think
that really makes for a better and more
enjoyable eating experience that's our
order thank you thank you oh that smells
oh it's all right just was a hard hit
there's something about food in a box
like this
I just love every time mmm it's like the
American bento box
nice you catch up with your fry I do
okay hold on I got all right let's dip
fry I mean what what okay I don't dump
this ketchup on your head do it I dare
you fries
mmm incredible fry it's crunchy like
cereal is crunchy okay let's go Sando
time oh look at that whoa
it feels wealthier than I thought that's
that potato butter Cheers
jarett's mm-hmm yeah a really good first
bite Wow mmm looking by it I've been
feeling everybody's gonna be good what
I'm realizing about this bun it's so
soft and fluffy that it is doing its job
in like making the fried chicken the
real star of the show so this is the why
are we having fried chicken as a
sandwich question you know cuz we've
done Fried Chicken before mm-hmm the bun
just dials the whole thing back into
like soft and donut territory huge I
kind of like you know what this does
kind of remind me of town I think you're
gonna be mad that you didn't think of no
I think it's gonna be lots of setting
than I thought the Peking Duck bun that
we had in New York that soft squishy bun
with a delicious meat in condiment and
crispy vegetable plus the cucumber and
the sweetness you're right okay yeah
yeah
American Beauty what a beautiful time in
America that's too easy for you
I'm disappointed okay so before our next
proper fried chicken sandwich we're
actually gonna have a bonus piece of
fried chicken friend of the show David
Chang has a number of fried chicken
sandwich shops called fuku they have an
off-menu mega spicy fried chicken
designed to taste better as a cold
products it's like a food pun but in the
language of flavor and temperature
that's more like an oxymoron it's like a
fun you got to be it oxymoron to eat
this
okay you know it's terrifying black
gloves that come with your food here it
is oh whoa put your gloves on
this guy is walking his dog and he's
just looking at three guys probably got
a black gloves oh my god it looks upset
oh it looks like mummify to me why is it
so dark I wish you had that bottle of
ranch on stand behind I know we're just
different this is so bizarre like cheers
oh oh oh it's like cinnamon sugar e200
it's bad there's pickles that you can
have alongside hey ah no I don't like
this give me that back okay
hot cold fried chicken fact I'm hmm
well that's good an ice slush drink
speaking of worse you say hot cold
chicken time cold fact in time oh wow
the chemical and spicy foods that make
something spicy is capsaicin capsaicin
is known to increase energy reduce
appetite increased salvation and release
endorphins ability to taste produces in
higher temperatures above 80 degrees
Fahrenheit as well as lower tempers
below 60 degrees Fahrenheit oh I think
this chicken might be right in the
center it's still going oh my goodness
so we're on our way downtown to be
Kuniko we're gonna see chef koneko and
have her fried chicken sandwich okay
it's a spicy no it's okay okay yeah
pequeñito means picnic plus clinic oh so
everything is an to-go box you can eat
outside of the restaurant like a picnic
why did you choose fried chicken as the
cornerstone of the menu I grew up with
it my grandma never liked cooking so we
always go by when I came here I ate the
southern style fried chicken with thick
thick crust and I loved it so I did a
hybrid light as Japanese but also
crunches normally it's a wheat flour but
we do brown rice and potato starch
that's maybe the most special part of
our fried chicken our fryer don't carry
any Goodison a lot of my friends kids
there are serious allergy and they never
eaten fried chicken so and I said ok you
can come here why did you want to offer
a sandwich option for your fried chicken
I'm trying to belong here do you ever
find those in Japan I don't believe it's
a popular thing Japanese just pack rice
ball and fried chicken and pickles and
that's our picnic but a lot of people
said clinic come on like a you live in
United States like everybody loves
sandwich come up with a great one I
wanted to make that sound it's as
special as I could we created a golden
button which carries turmeric the
turmeric is like anti-family so you can
listen your feeling of our meeting fried
chicken turn to me sandwich is about
combination the soft bun
crunchy chicken acid from the lemon
vinaigrette I wanted to have everything
in one bite I mean you say one bite but
I've seen the sandwich and it's quite
tall yeah how do I eat that with one
bite smash we've come for the sandwiches
but we also got a salad No
my first I like my seaweed and cucumber
salad our cvd from Japan and it's so
cured the texture is not like dehydrated
like welcoming like a paper thing
it's very meaty and satisfying I eat my
salad every day Cheers hmm Wow
I'm not sure I've ever had this type of
seaweed before it is denser in meteor
pause button back to the sandwich she
gave us good advice to smush oh look how
juicy the triviality juices coming out
it's the hidden benefit of the squish
Cheers
[Music]
that's awesome
Wow it's a face wiper for sure it's a
very good sandwich dude the star of this
fried chicken sandwich say it on three
one two three the branch ah defend your
case cuz I think you're wrong
it's the sourness that makes you want
all the other stuff true
but come on look at this bread it's
squishy has a nice bite it's not all
apart
it's a beautiful sandwich the texture of
this stuff almost like moss like they
were like a moss and think I bet that's
tasty Valley they can be a cool texture
to eat it's like a hanging garden it's
like that plant up there I think this
makes like potentially the perfect
sandwich
you got this fried chicken that's
delicious but then the things are
rounded so that you're not feeling like
a easy son easy at all
[ __ ] fried chicken on this side right
she's like okay what do I put on this
side to balance it out spreads miso jam
pickles a little too far oh okay
jalapeno is on this side boom you like
we said some good stuff
dirty move Adam it's a dirty dirty move
they're eating the one that you didn't
already steal piece of chicken out of I
see I know how you work pika Nico what
do you think the brat so good I feel
like a picnic since before we go to our
next spot fried chicken sandwich speck
time fried chicken sandwich set though
it's not currently on the menu for a
time KFC offered the double down
sandwich I remember that one which
consisted of two fried chicken fillets
doubling as the bun and the filling was
bacon cheese and sauce I actually have a
very fond memory of this you actually
ate this thing I tried it it was as
amazing as it sounds
really I remember that thing that was
madness it's like just eat food guys
what are you doing is it even a sandwich
at that point or are you just picking up
food like if I just pick up a steak and
eat it with my hand is that a sandwich
we started this video at a steak house
mm-hmm now we're going to a seafood
restaurant oh okay we're on our way to
son-of-a-gun
where chef Greg is going to show us
their fried chicken sandwich and
probably a couple other seafood treats
is this modeled after a certain style or
like genre of seafood definitely Jon and
Vinny the owners are from Florida the
vibe of it is a Florida fish shack I
wonder why you put a fried chicken
sandwich on a menu of a secret
restaurant well our menu is really
diverse which is like the way we like to
eat living in Los Angeles you have so
much diversity as amazing food and
Koreatown amazing Chinese food in San
Gabriel you name it we got it here so
this is what influences our menu we're
not an Italian restaurant we're not a
French restaurant we just take something
that we're into at the time and try to
develop a dish to the tuna dish for
example exactly yeah that tuna dish is
influenced by Peruvian cuisine first we
take market avocado red onion cilantro
and some tortilla chips mix all that
together and then the tuna has been
pounded out into carpaccio so it makes
the texture of the fish really nice so
that gets wrapped around the
Mikado mix and then the bottom of the
bowl is alleged at tea grace so you eat
it with a spoon and get a little bit of
the tuna avocado tortilla chips all
together delightful this reminds me of
our time at Pacific Seas remember that I
don't exist in this bar as you know me
we've shared like one doughnut
wait whoa okay these are the coolest all
they've ever seen this is a drink you
don't have to Cheers
because how would you like this I'm
concerned because I taste no alcohol in
there but I definitely feel like oka huh
in here all right
Oh a stir time hmm yeah I mean you met
me and then you got hoarse ready for you
good yeah Cheers
Oh hmm
hell yeah okay turn it on I think
moister czar the most Disney Princess
food it's like a spoon made of an ocean
fish and so it makes me feel like I'm in
a Little Mermaid you get what I mean no
I'm not picking up what you're laying
down people are shaking their heads but
those people haven't been having
scorpion balls
whoa wildest looking thing I've ever
seen it looks like a whole brain on a
plate whoa Wow
[Music]
goddamnit that spoon oh my god that's
good look at how much avocado is in this
juice at the bottom it's like spicy
orange juice this is more of a cocktail
than this yeah hold up no Steven you're
mad man I was saying it tastes more like
a cocktail with in the squirt I said
that not you we take a free-range
chicken breast brined overnight in some
lemon and herbs read it with a three
step breading process seasoned flour
into buttermilk and then we make crumbs
out of the flour and the buttermilk so
it gives it a crispy texture when we fry
the chicken and let it rest that the
juices reabsorb and then we use a Red
Rooster aioli which is Red Rooster hot
sauce from Louisiana it's not sure Aceh
it's more like Tabasco and then we make
a slaw with a market vegetables we make
some bread and butter pickles in-house
here so we'll make the dressing for the
cabbage slaw from the vinegar that comes
from the pickles thank you okay this
should not at all what I expected to see
there's pickles embedded into the slaw
it's my kind of slaw have you ever seen
a more beautiful chicken sandwich
commercial perfect okay I'm gonna split
it for us you're gonna love the feel of
this but I can already tell yeah yeah
you're a big bun guy oh these dishes are
actually very similar there's like the
fattiness and the acidity yeah fattiness
acidity thanks acidity fatty this
acidity fattiness acidity whoa whoa whoa
whoa you're gonna set me up like that
when i dunk hard how's that for a sports
Cheers the mmm
you know you had a good time when the
sandwich is in shambles what do you
think about the the texture of the fried
crust it sound like you want to talk
about the texture of the fried crust
Andrew yeah no there's different levels
of crunch a crunch your crunch would be
like leaves high pitch crackle then is
also lower pitch crackle like stepping
into snow I think this is more like snow
crackle the other chicken we've had is
more like leaf crackle I want spinach in
one day I want spend a day in your head
just like what are you thinking all
right Stephen we do yin that only did we
have three fried chicken sandwiches but
this also concludes a three Episode set
for us the first one had buns the last
one had buns in effect it was a sandwich
of its own what was your favorite thing
in this episode that was not a fried
chicken sandwich the giant ropes that
held the hanging light bulbs at key
Kuniko yes we don't often get to talk
about restaurant decor I kind of have a
similar favorite thing that wasn't a
fried chicken sandwich
ah the bathroom faucets at American
Beauty it looked like a swan throwing up
the water interior all right which fried
chicken sandwich was the most worth it
at its given price why were that winner
goes through the window at American
Beauty that fried chicken sandwich is
everything I wanted on a Martin's potato
roll which is near and dear to my heart
you know often wrong on the show but
you're wrong today oh my word that
winner goes to be good to go that fried
chicken sandwich was so special yeah
the smashing today was pretty excellent
Adam who's your worth the winner Adam
picks B Kuniko a good Pete Kuniko and
that's gonna be up for 2019 thanks to
everybody who works on this show to make
it happen most of them are not here and
thank you all for watching appreciate it
we'll be back if you want to suggest the
food we do check our Instagram page
instagram.com slash BuzzFeed worth it in
the comments of this video comments
video probably reading them right now as
you're watching this I am also watching
oh yeah what have we learned about fried
chicken delicious well
fried chicken sandwiches may continue to
be eaten the world
at least we'll know that they taste good
so
[Music]
[Applause]